La cuestión es, hay muchas cosas cualitativas
que simplemente no podemos entender.
Piensen cuando escucharon su canción favorita por primera vez.
¿Qué estaban haciendo?
¿Cómo se sintieron?
¿Sintieron escalofríos?
¿Estaban entusiasmados?
Difícil de describir, ¿no?
Partes de nosotros parecen muy simples,
pero bajo la superficie hay toneladas de complejidad.
Y trasladar esa complejidad a las máquinas
es lo que hace a los modernos hitos históricos.
Y no estoy convencido de que podamos responder estas preguntas complejas
solo con unos y ceros.
En el laboratorio, he creando arte
como medio para ayudarme a diseñar mejores experiencias
para el último grito en tecnología.
Ha servido como catalizador
para reforzar maneras humanas en que
los ordenadores pueden relacionarse con nosotros.
A través del arte, abordamos algunas preguntas difíciles,
como, ¿qué significa realmente sentir?
O cómo involucrarnos y conocer cómo estar presentes para el otro.
O cómo la intuición afecta la manera en que interactuamos.
Tomemos por ejemplo la emoción humana.
Los ordenadores pueden sentir nuestras emociones más básicas,
como alegría, tristeza, enfado, miedo y disgusto,
convirtiendo estas características en matemáticas.
¿Y qué hay de las emociones más complejas?
Saben, ¿esas emociones que nos cuesta describir al otro?
Como la nostalgia.
Para explorar esto, he creado una obra de arte, una experiencia,
que pide a la gente compartir sus recuerdos
y los uno a algunos datos científicos
para descubrir cómo tomar emociones muy subjetivas
y convertirlas en algo matemáticamente preciso.
Creamos una puntuación de nostalgia
y es el corazón de esta instalación.
Para conseguir esto, el sistema te pide compartir una historia,
el ordenador la analiza por sus emociones más simples,
y comprueba la tendencia a usar palabras en pasado
y busca palabras que tendemos a asociar con la nostalgia,
como "casa", "infancia" y "el pasado".
Luego crea una puntuación de nostalgia
que indica cuán nostálgica es su historia.
Y la puntuación es la impulsora que hay detrás de estas esculturas de luz
que sirven como encarnaciones físicas de su contribución.
Cuanto más alta la puntuación, más rosa es el tono.
Es como mirar el mundo a través de lentes rosas.
Así, cuando uno ve su puntuación
y su representación física,
a veces estará de acuerdo, y a veces no lo estará.
Es como si realmente entendiera cómo lo hizo sentir esa experiencia.
Pero otras veces tropieza de tal modo
que piensa que no le ha entendido en absoluto.
Pero la obra sirve para mostrar
que si se nos hace difícil explicar las emociones que tenemos a otro,
¿cómo enseñar a un ordenador a darles sentido?
Incluso las partes más objetivas de los humanos son difíciles de describir.
Como la conversación.
¿Alguna vez han intentado descomponer sus partes?
Piensen en estar sentados con un amigo en una cafetería
teniendo una conversación trivial.
¿Cómo saben cuándo dar un giro a la conversación?
¿Cómo saben cuándo cambiar de tema?
¿Y cómo saben, incluso, sobre qué tema discutir?
La mayoría no piensa sobre esto,
parece algo natural.
Cuando conocemos a alguien, sabemos cómo manejar esto,
y aprendemos qué temas discutir.
Pero cuando se trata de enseñar a enseñar a la IA a interactuar con gente,
tenemos que enseñarle paso por paso qué hacer.
Y ahora mismo, parece difícil.
Si incluso tratan de hablar con Alexa, Siri o el asistente de Google,
pueden decir que él o ellos aún suenan fríos.
Y, ¿alguna vez incluso se han enfadado
cuando no han comprendido qué estaban diciendo
y tienen que reformular 20 veces lo que dicen para reproducir una canción?
Para dar crédito a los diseñadores, la comunicación realista es muy difícil.
Y hay una rama completa de la sociología,
llamada análisis de la conversación,
que intenta hacer planos de los diferentes tipos de conversación.
Tipos como servicio al cliente, consejeros, enseñanza y otros.
He estado colaborando con un analista de la conversación en el laboratorio
para tratar de ayudar a los sistemas de IA a mantener conversaciones más humanas.
Cuando tienes una interacción con un chatbox en tu teléfono
o sistemas basados en voz en tu coche,
suena un poco más humano y menos frío e inconexo.
He creado una obra de arte
que trata de iluminar la robótica, la interacción difícil
para ayudarnos a entender, como diseñadores,
por qué no suena humano aún, y qué podemos hacer.
Esta obra se llama Bot to Bot
y pone un sistema a conversar con otro
y lo expone al público general.
Y uno acaba teniendo algo
que intenta imitar la conversación humana,
pero se queda corto.
A veces funciona y a veces se queda en estos, bueno,
ciclos de malentendidos.
Aunque una conversación máquina a máquina pueda tener sentido,
gramatical y coloquialmente,
aún sigue pareciendo algo frío y robótico.
Y, a pesar de cumplir todos los puntos, el diálogo carece de alma
y esa peculiaridad única hace de cada uno lo que es.
Puede que si bien podía ser gramaticalmente correcto
y usa todos los hashtags y emojis correctos,
acaba sonando mecánico, y bueno, un poco siniestro.
Y lo llamamos valle misterioso.
El factor siniestro de la tecnología
donde es cercana a lo humano pero está fuera de lugar.
Y la pieza acabará siendo
una forma de probar la humanidad en una conversación
y las piezas perdidas en la traducción.
Hay otras cosas perdidas en la traducción, también,
como la intuición humana.
Ahora, los ordenadores están ganando más autonomía.
Pueden hacer cosas por nosotros,
como cambiar la temperatura de casa según nuestras preferencias
e incluso nos ayudan a conducir por la autopista.
Pero hay cosas que Uds. y yo hacemos en persona
que son difíciles de traducir a IA.
Piensen en la última vez que vieron a un antiguo compañero de clase o colega.
¿Los abrazo o les dio la mano?
Probablemente no lo pensó
porque han tenido tantas experiencias acumuladas
que les hizo hacer uno u otro.
Y como artista, siento el acceso a la propia intuición,
el conocimiento inconsciente,
que nos ayuda a crear cosas maravillosas.
Grandes ideas, de lo abstracto, en un lugar de nuestra consciencia
que es la culminación de todas nuestras experiencias.
Si queremos que se relacionen con nosotros y ayudan a amplificar habilidades creativas,
necesitamos empezar a pensar cómo hacer que sean intuitivos.
Quiero explorar cómo algo como la intuición humana
puede ser directamente traducida a la inteligencia artificial.
Y creé una obra que explora ordenadores basados en intuición
en un espacio físico.
Esta obra se llama Wayfinding, está configurada
como una brújula simbólica que tiene cuatro esculturas quinéticas.
Cada una representa una dirección,
norte, este, sur y oeste.
Y hay sensores configurados encima de cada escultura
que capturan cuán lejos estás de ellas.
Y los datos que coleccionan
acaban cambiando la forma en que la escultura se mueve
y la dirección de la brújula.
La cosa es, la pieza no funciona como una puerta automática
que solo se abre cuando uno pasa frente a ella.
La contribución es solo una parte de nuestras experiencias vividas.
Y esas experiencias afectan la manera en que se mueve.
Cuando uno camina frente a ella,
empieza a usar todos los datos
que capturó a lo largo de su historial de exposición,
o es intuición,
para responder mecánicamente basado en lo que aprendió de otros.
Y lo que acaba pasando es que como participantes
empezamos a aprender el nivel de detalles que necesitamos
para manejar las expectativas
tanto de humanos como de máquinas.
Casi podemos ver nuestra intuición interpretada en el ordenador,
imaginando todos los datos siendo procesados por el ojo de la mente.
Mi esperanza es que este tipo de arte
nos ayudará a pensar diferente sobre nuestra intuición
y cómo aplicarla a la IA en el futuro.
Son unos cuantos efectos sobre cómo uso el arte para avivar mi trabajo
como diseñador e investigador de inteligencia artificial.
Y lo veo como una forma crucial para avanzar en innovación.
Hay un montón de extremos cuando nos referimos a la IA.
Películas famosas la muestran como esta fuerza destructiva
mientras la publicidad la muestra como una salvadora
para resolver alguno de los problemas más complejos del mundo.
Pero independientemente de donde te encuentres
es difícil negar que vivimos en un mundo
que se vuelve más digital a cada segundo.
Nuestras vidas giran en torno a nuestros dispositivos y demás
Y no creo que esto desaparezca pronto.
Intento incrustar más humanidad desde el principio.
Tengo la corazonada de que llevar el arte al proceso de investigación IA
es una manera de hacer esto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)